This is.
Is a complicated subject, but I, myself was so, uh,
I decided to journey out from the world of being a researcher at
MIT and potentially doing a startup myself.
And I've been thinking of, you know,
I wanted to come to Silicon Valley to do so. It's the land of the entrepreneur.
And there's a lot of my friends,
a lot of them are successfully have been entrepreneurs themselves has said,
do not come to Silicon Valley. Uh, it'd be you've. You've started you,
you ran amazing teams of engineers. You started a lot of successful businesses.
I wondered if you could comment on why a lot of people are leaving
California. Is there something that could be fixed about California?
If you were starting a business today,
would you consider somewhere else like Austin or some other place,
or is Silicon Valley still?
Is it just a little lull everybody's being overdramatic during this particular
year of the coronavirus and so on?
I think, you know, even Austin is getting overheated. I hear, um,
and I've had relatives and friends moved to Texas within the last few months.
So, uh, Texas as a whole is a big place. And, uh, you know,
people are moving to Florida. There's a big movement toward Miami. Um,
Peter teal, Keith affordable, all these people. Um, the mayor has been very, uh,
business friendly about it, which I think is just good politics. Um,
the America is fundamentally commercial Republic.
So you would think this would be what's happening for a long time.
California was the golden state. I came here in late 76 when I was a teenager.
Um, it's in crushing debt to do the lockdowns.
It's got the highest taxes that's gonna matter.
People will do flee tat high taxes. Um, it's got, uh,
likely fires every year because of the dead fall.
It's not global warming it's because the forests weren't managed like they had
been in the first part of the 20th century. Um, just,
I would say corruption at all levels, especially up to the governor who,
you know,
famously was eating at the French laundry in a claim that the outside it wasn't
inside and they were out masks off and it was great. Uh, do what I say,
not what I do, uh, rules for the, but not for me.
When you see that in leadership people either run or they,
they get rid of the leadership. So there's a recall drive,
which is about to reach the threshold or in the old days they get their guns,
right? Yeah. You don't put up with this junk, but ultimately.
The, the thing that made Silicon Valley a special place,
it gave freedom to like young kids, entrepreneurs,
young minds, brave minds to, to think bold, to try different stuff.
I mean, even if the taxes are high, so outside of financial stuff,
outside of all of that housing, super expensive housing. So it's hard. Okay.
Everything about startups.
Euro and the, and they didn't plan the roads, right? Yeah.
They got rid of public transportation in LA, like the who framed Roger rabbit,
cartoon show these trolley cars and Portland to the oil companies in the
DOD conspired to build highways and make cars dominant.
And the rights of way are long gone. Like Elan's going to go underground.
I wished him, well, it's probably the only way to do it now, but.
There's still a place.
Do you think it's possible that Silicon Valley is still a place where magic
happens, where the next Google's built, where the next, I mean,
brave is built where, uh.
All good things come to an end.
I think the problem is Silicon Valley had strong network effects through
Stanford, through the angel investor networks and the wealth effect.
And originally you have to give the federal government credit.
Like the ARPANET was a government project. That's not kid ourselves,
this wasn't wild free market, you know, libertarian capitalism.
This was all cold war stuff. Um, you had, uh, out of the academia,
you had Shockley. And then the, the, the trader is aid in Fairchild and Intel.
And, but now, you know,
once the last fab that was built in the Valley micro unit,
you might've been the last time. I don't know, I haven't followed it.
We built a fab in Sunnyvale and, uh,
and micro unity in starting early nineties. And now the fabs are overseas.
Um,
and the one thing that I will say that the oligarchs have intentionally done in
both parties is sort of labor and environmental protection law arbitrage
by going where the labor is cheaper and the environmental laws aren't as strict.
And, you know, that's polluted the hell out of parts of China,
but it's made things you can make cheaper junk. And, uh, this, this is not,
uh, this is not a story that's over yet. So what is Silicon Valley for now?
It's for the network effect, the, the, the brain trust of who, you know,
the parties, the Stanford's, um,
sort of network that's fragile too, over time. I'm afraid, right?
Stanford. Uh, a lot of good professors are like, uh,
they still filter, you know, mainly based on socioeconomic status,
but it's kind of a skate school.
I had a friend hired out of Harvard 20 years ago at Netscape,
and we talked about Harvard and he said, yeah,
there's still professors are great on the curve. And I said, Oh yeah,
I don't think there are any doing that at Stanford. He said, yo,
it was shocking. Some of the students got seasoned these and they were crying.
I was like, yes, that's right. The precious dears can't take that at Stanford.
So they get A's and B's now you look at China and people say,
what you all about China? They true Russia too, that a lot of math,
science training, a lot of engineering,
a lot of people who are doing their coursework to get the A's and B's
so, um, I'm an American I'm born in the 4th of July,
4th of July, July. Wow. And in America, as I say,
fundamentally as a commercial Republic, you can try to make it something else.
You can see it's the new Atlantis and mystify it. You could,
you could talk about it in a more, I think correct way,
which is 13 colonies that grew,
and then there's a lot of local or written original design. Anyway,
the federal Federalist papers talk about this. There's a lot of subsidiarity,
but that's, that's been eroded over time. And like I say,
a lot of the offshoring has hurt.
So what happened with coronavirus people working from home?
And at first it was funny.
Cause I have friends at Google who used to grumble that not only did they have
to come into the office,
if they joined a different team that was centered at a different office,
they had to move. Or, you know, if, if,
if the VA team was reconstituted in Munich,
which it was after Lara's booked got tired of JavaScript that they hired in
Munich, or they hired PhDs in Germany and moved to Munich, um, with coronavirus,
everyone's working from home and it's like, well, I really,
if I can work for Google from home, but then the next shoe dropped,
then people started asking Mark soccer bird, Hey,
can I move to my hometown in the Midwest? Yeah. And he said, okay.
And they said, Oh, can I keep getting myself in Valley pay? No,
we're going to figure out why your cost of living there. Isn't,
we're going to adjust your pay. Of course.
And these colonies in these little mini experiments that all combined to the big
giant experiment, I have a, I don't know I have this, uh,
vision of America, which the countries I was born in Russia, like I said here,
and this is a truly wonderful country. I, um, I wasn't born on the 4th of July.
My sloppy people still fly. I still,
and I'm a red blooded American at this point.
And I have a sense that we figured it out somehow, if so,
come Valley burns and other places will come up in this place that we even more
innovation and people will move.
And the remote work might change fundamentally how we work or might
not. It might just give you the freedom to then create many other small Silicon
valleys throughout the place that Austin included, but other places as well.
And we somehow figure it, figure it out. And, uh.
I think that's,
that's true that there will be more mobility and maybe new places that come up.
I don't know if Silicon Valley has, you know, passed some sell by date because,
um, it did hurt the coronavirus hurt,
the lockdowns hurt and the FA in the sense that part of what keeps things going
is social. And so a lot of young people,
even before coronavirus moved to San Francisco,
it was very strange to watch because in the eighties we all lived in the Valley
and it was less populated in San Francisco was grungy,
or it was more like dirty Harry in the seventies. But, but by the nineties, uh,
and Jamie runs a nightclub there, and he's talked about this,
you had sort of wealthy tech people moving in South of market,
fancy townhouses being built. And, uh,
that's continued in such a point that it's almost like what's the movie by the
South African director, Nels, Jodie foster up in the space colony. Uh,
Matt Damon is the guy in the earth who has to go up. And anyway,
it's about the stratification. It's about the great inequality.
The people in the space station have like amazing medical auto docs that can
extend their life or save them, cure cancer.
People on the earth are all suffering ground down in poverty. Um,
and, uh, you know, that sort of happened while I was here.
You saw a lot of money drive prices up along the narrow
peninsula and the single people wanted nightlife.
So they were in the city and the condos in the city got super expensive. And,
you know, even Google friends who are, you know, socially responsible say,
we should have more housing built. We should have yes. In my backyard, not,
not in my backyard, but that's not happening. Uh, as far I can tell,
and from the government to the incumbent landowners and renters,
it's just not happening. And that has to drive people away. I,
I appreciate that when people come here and you should wait for the prices to
monitor, they will. But, um,
but a lot of people are going to go where the prices are lower.